greates everyone I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel where today I am unboxing
the Xbox elite wireless controller
series 2 I'm very excited about this the
elite is my favorite controller ever
made I still have it plugged in use it
very regularly whether on PC or whether
on my xbox and I feel like it's
difficult to argue how good this
controller is when it's basically
extremely customizable more so than
virtually any other controller on the
market so then they announced they were
coming out with a series 2 which is even
more customizable
and I've been very excited since then
announcement this also has something to
do with Taco Bell I don't know what that
is but I guess were about to find out
fun fact I've never had talked about or
rather I've never been in a Taco Bell so
the fact that I have 2x boxes that make
taco bell sounds is sort of insane I
think I also want to get me talked about
one time we were road tripping from San
Francisco to Vegas for CES I had
pneumonia so I was on a lot of drugs and
that's what I had for dinner anyway here
it is beautiful elite Oh series 2 I hope
that you don't get mad at me for not
taking you out to dinner first but it's
a nice box
I'm sorry I'll stop I do have it cut up
and ready to be revealed but I thought I
would read the Box first mentions two
interchangeable d-pad 6 interchangeable
thumb sticks to paddle sets a carrying
case a charging dock a thumb stick
adjustment tool which is new and very
cool and it's also USB see this time
around so let's open it up this is the
second box I've tried to open today
weather like so airtight that you trying
to get it out it just doesn't even ok I
actually haven't looked at it let's just
pull that up boom first things first
super sleek carrying case take that out
there is of course the cable in this
part of the show of the box oh USBC
cable pretty good length if you can tell
from this video it seems pretty good to
me
time don't under this bad boy you ready
I'm excited it looks damn good obviously
down here we have the extra thumb sticks
the extra d-pad here it's currently got
this thumb stick which via other elite
also has which is my preferred for
fighting games particularly and then
this thing right here which is what lets
you adjust your thumb stick basically
lets you tighten so you can choose how
much resistance you're actually getting
on each part of the controller which i
think is incredibly cool I mean I'm sure
a lot of you who are watching this if
I've done it a lot of other people have
surely done it way you use a controller
so much that you wear it down like the
thumbs little chunks stop coming off if
you're using something that much I think
you'd be surprised by how much
customization options will actually make
a difference to how you play and how
much comfort you have while playing I'm
gonna take it out and touch it
oh that's what she said
and she took it out as she touched it
it's beautiful
it's so oh my god the the buttons feel
huh
maybe this is because it's brand-new but
they like more grippy somehow that's
cool it's lighter than I expected
otherwise everything feels pretty
familiar I really do like the grip on
the besides here I don't feel like it
looks like a design that's still really
sleek which is nice it also has a grip
on the back here let me zoom in for that
the triggers have grip on them as well
which I really like it feels nice
obviously you can still shorten your
triggers very easy make them feel more
like buttons for people who prefer that
if you weren't familiar with the elite
one you just do that by upping and
downing this there are three options on
the back here so let's then let's try
the middle one one and one you still
feel great you can take them off super
easily yeah this thing's gorgeous but
let's swap out some foam sticks shall we
see how easy that is to do Oh like way
easier than I thought it would be it's
that's just a little magnet just
virtually no force at all required whip
I'm gonna show you how the tightening
works as best I can
obviously you can't feel it so it's
difficult to actually demonstrate I did
get a hands on with one of these at e3
so I already knew that I was really
impressed by it but basically this thing
slots in here and you push down and you
twist in either direction to change how
tight it is or is not basically it'll go
down or up depending on how you have it
set a different kind of thumb stick on
here here we go
super easy again this one's a little
more flat face less grip
this is the one that's on the other
elite it's like rough on the edges which
I like
I mean honestly these these thumb sticks
feel incredibly different this is really
big
comparatively really big I feel like I
might like using that for say like an
RPG where I'm having no press for what a
lot run forward in the same direction a
lot I've also got this guy here it's
more rounded got three circles on the
face yep feels good man let me see if I
can show you the the difference in
tightness nice why does it keep
happening in this video it's gotta
tighten her up you know all right we did
it
if I am to flick that you can see that
that's easy and quick and I'm really
just flicking it this one which has now
been tightened it looks exactly the same
but I swear it feels different
basically when you've tightened it I
want to say it feels heavy oh it feels
like like the literal thumb stick weighs
more so to do a side-by-side my two
elites they are very similar looking
with the same size the same shape in
virtually every way some slight
differences in the middle of the faces
here and obviously the grip looks very
different the back is more different
three options two options for your
trigger lengths this only has a built in
battery this has a replaceable battery I
prefer the built-in battery I wish that
Xbox had done that the whole time rather
than making people buy reach out rolled
battery packs the DualShock is great for
that but in terms of gaming and comfort
I am all about it it feels great
I'm like excited in a way that's
exceptionally lame it's not like oh I've
been looking forward to this game for
ages can't wait I'm like oh I look
forward to holding this thing in my
hands for 12 hours straight I've
actually always preferred
the xbox360 controller to the ps3
controller I prefer the Xbox one control
it to the ps4 controller I think in a
lot of cases that's just preference
supposedly these controllers are
designed with the sticks being opposite
to each other in a Nintendo did the same
thing I feel like I said Nintendo weird
the Nintendo because supposedly the
science is that it's more comfortable
for humans if the thumbsticks are not
parallel and I feel like that works for
me obviously doesn't work for a lot of
people who prefer the Dual Shock but I
do love that the Jill show has that
built-in battery I really like the
microphone and I love the light I think
the light on the front of the DualShock
is a really cool touch in a lot of ways
I love it if they added that to an elite
series 3 in some way and the motion
controls which I didn't use a lot but
it's nice to have the option everyone
else is doing it but otherwise yeah
people were saying you know some reviews
have just come out that this is the best
controller ever made
I can't tell you I 100% agree until I
played on it more but right now I think
the elite one is so I imagine I will
feel the same way about the elite series
too which is beautiful do you have to
disclose that Microsoft sent this to me
I did not buy it that is why I have it
early Thank You Microsoft assigning one
because I again have been excited about
it for ages but if anybody is actually
curious I will let you know how I like
it and how it goes I'm excited to play
with it the innuendos right themselves
for [ __ ] sake I'm a child
thank you guys for watching this quick
silly unboxing I have not had much time
at all for anything over the past couple
of weeks I've been doing a lot of
different stuff that's why I haven't
streamed in a bit it's why I didn't make
a YouTube videos more consistently over
the last couple of weeks should have
more time back though now hopefully
we'll see all righty guys I'm Alana I'll
see you next time